speaking of a furious basement dwelling Trump,
this is fascinating and hilarious.
Donald Trump has been completely embarrassed.
By world leaders, including the German chancellor,
Angela Merkel, who turned down Trump's invitation
to come to the U.S. for the G7 summit at the
White House.
So understand the backstory for a few weeks
now.
The White House has continued to talk about.
We want to do the G-7 rebe.
We might do it at Camp David.
We might do it at the White House.
Corona virus.
No, I think we're gonna be able to do it.
It's gonna be really, really great.
And reporters smartly were asking, should
you be doing this, given the pandemic?
But also, which world leaders have accepted
your invitation so far?
And they didn't say, but they just kept insisting
Trump did.
And Kaley McEnany, world leaders are reacting
very favorably.
We're gonna have news about this soon, yada,
yada, yada.
Hopefully it'll happen at the end of June.
Everything's gonna be fine.
We suspected this was B.S.
Most world leaders clearly, from what they
say, understand this is not the time to be
traveling all over the world, possibly spreading
corona virus to come and give Trump his photo
op at the White House or Camp David.
And one of the first to turn down the invitation
over the weekend was German Chancellor Angela
Merkel, who essentially said no thanks.
She said, I'm not going.
It's too early to reopen.
We shouldn't be having large gatherings.
The virus is very much circulating.
And Trump reportedly furious at Angela Merkel.
And then Trump does this thing that, you know,
it's not surprising, but it's so pathetic.
Trump decides to pretend it was really his
decision not to do the G-7 and that the countries
that are currently in it aren't really the
right ones.
Calls it an outdated group.
And according to press pool reports, Donald
Trump said, I'm postponing it because I don't
feel as a G-7.
It probably represents what's going on in
the world.
It's a very outdated group.
Trump mentioning that he wants to add Russia
and some other countries to the group.
So this is an obvious lie.
Trump is postponing it because nobody's coming.
They've turned down the invitation.
At least Angela Merkel has.
World leaders said no.
And now Trump is pretending he didn't want
it to happen with this group anyway.
And the entire, you know, adding Russia thing
and the group being outdated.
This is how Trump attacks people that don't
want to say yes to him.
Quite simply, it's just everything is a childish
temper tantrum now.
Just imagine what Trump will do if he loses
in November.
It will be like nothing we have seen before
from any president.
One other sort of interesting thing about
the whole G-7 fiasco.
This is why diplomats exist in a normal administration.
You don't have Trump for a month saying we're
going to push for G-7.
And the leaders are reacting very positively,
very strong, positive reactions in a normal
situation.
Diplomats figure all of this out.
You don't put Trump out there on a limb saying
we're doing the G-7 and we're doing it here,
even though they're not actually yet scheduled
to do it.
Then you end up with world leaders saying
no thanks.
And Trump tries to save face by saying, well,
I want better countries in it anyway in a
normal administration DEP.
Diplomats handle this.
There will be one statement about it.
And it is either we have decided to postpone
the G-7 due to corona virus fears or we are
confirmed having the G7 on such and such date.
You avoid all of these embarrassing fiascos
in the first place.
This is all self harm done by Donald Trump,
and the degree to which he is being shunned
by world leaders is really representative
of just a slide down the totem pole, so to
speak, for the U.S. presidency globally.
It's embarrassing to Americans.
It needs to change.
And just imagine, this is what Trump is doing
over Angela Merkel saying no thanks.
Just imagine what he will do if he is indeed
defeated in November.